welcome to a wonderful session today to
journey to hope recovery and beyond that
is supported by the Pointer fellowship
at Yale which is a an entity that is a
wonderful group that can support
bringing people to New Haven to
stimulate learning and dialogue and and
connect us to the broader intellectual
world that influences us we're
particularly honored today to have as
our pointer followed Johnny Benjamin and
Johnny is a mental health campaigner
advocate author and vlogger and you know
I it's particularly inspiring when we
have people who make use of the
diversity of the kind of experiences
that people are exposed to and and and
have a positive impact as a result of
their unique experiences in Johnny's
case he began having mental health
problems in childhood and had auditory
hallucinations which many of you know to
be a common symptom of some psychiatric
disorders he later developed depression
and eventually was diagnosed with
schizoaffective disorder a variant of
schizophrenia in his early 20s he was
hospitalized in 2008 and at that time he
ran away or left the hospital of ran
away so value judgment in but left the
hospital but he was intending to take
his own life and in particular he was
thinking about jumping off a bridge and
and someone passed by and found him
while he was thinking about committing
suicide and and convinced him not to
take his own life
and this moment was inspiring for him
and he may talk about this today with
find my campaign which
had an enormous impact in 2011 he began
vlogging about his experiences on
YouTube and and was able to make use of
this evolving platform now something
people might are used to using it's part
of everybody's daily life but was able
to use this to reach an enormous number
of people and to help people to
understand mental illness and the
opportunities also from treatment in
2012 he published a book of poems called
pill after pill poems from a
schizophrenic mind and in the poetry for
that book actually was written in part
while he was hospitalized in 2008 by
2013 his vlogs had drawn thousands of
views and he received the first annual
Jani Anton award from a mental health
charity called rethink mental illness
for his mental health advocacy and then
2014 he launched his groundbreaking fine
mic campaign and because he didn't know
the name of the person that contacted
you and helped you to rethink rethink
your plan for suicide and the rationale
is is so consistent with everything that
he's done which is that that hearing
voices or having suicidal feelings or
becoming depressed or whatever the the
emotional or chant other challenge that
you're experiencing these are in in
their own way common experiences that
that that they shouldn't be
marginalizing or disenfranchising
experiences that lead people to be
isolated and not get the help that they
need and so so it was such a clearly
important process that so many people
like Stephen Fry or Boy George or
British Prime Minister David Cameron got
involved in this incredible
effort in 2016 johnny launched thinkwell
which helped to bring mental health
education into schools and and help
young people who are going through
things that they don't understand to
have some some sense that that that
they're not alone in their experiences
in 2016 he also received MBE
which is a member of the most excellent
Order of the British Empire - you don't
get like a sword and shield with that do
you but it's very it's a really high
honor and that's really it's a wonderful
way of recognizing his his important
contributions and then in May of this
year he published his memoir titled
stranger on the bridge and which is I
think will be some of which are which
are drawn on today so Johnny we're
thrilled to have you here really
appreciate it the long travel that you
had to go through to get here and we're
really looking forward to this session
so thank you I'm I'm gonna just say a
few more words because Johnny and I know
each other a little bit more personally
my name is Phil call it I'm a faculty
member here in the security department
and I like to think a lot about how
people think about themselves and I
think we all like to think about
ourselves in certain ways we like to
think that we're better friends and
better partners that we are we rate
ourselves as better drivers on average
than everybody else and that can't
statistically be possible I think what
we're gonna hear about today is a story
of people who actually lived up to some
of those expectations we're gonna hear
about Neil and Johnny on that bridge
Neil making a decision to reach out to
Johnny at a time when clearly he needed
a lot of help but it was I don't think
it was an easy decision I don't think
it's a decision that all of us would
have taken and I think that's one of the
more inspiring things about this story
and then everything that happened next
is just so incredible Johnny
sharing and communicating and reaching
out to people about the things that he'd
experienced things that we liked
keep personal things that we don't think
his are a good idea to share feeling
vulnerable not having that sort of
classic British stiff upper lip which
were all somewhat stricken by at times I
defy you all not to be moved by this
story and not to feel emotional today
I've heard it many times and it still
moves me and I'm just really excited
that we can bring them here today and
have them share it with us so please
Johnny thank you very much hello yeah
working great what a great introduction
no expectation to live up to whatsoever
so as you heard yeah just to you know
clarify who is who this is Johnny
Benjamin MBE and I'm Nili born . and
we're also we're also joined by Johnny
Quinn Austin in the front raise your
hands on me and his brother Wesley
Austin as well so that's us and as you
heard you know Johnny's had quite the
the journey and yet he's been all over
the world newspapers magazines books and
if you're wondering where else you might
have seen him he's on tinder quite a lot
so that could be if you swipe left or
right I don't use it but yeah so
essentially what we'd like to do is put
across what we hope is is an important
and powerful message and we'd like to do
that just by using the power of
narrative and there there's a few key
messages that we would like to hit along
the way and hopefully we'll explain
those what we really love actually is
afterwards if there's any open dialogue
comments and particularly questions that
you guys might like to ask while you
have the opportunity and while we're in
the room not only ourselves with such
great experts so really really would
encourage those questions and we're
shameless we will talk about anything
so please do ask crunches for time I
think we're supposed to have a hard
finish about one o'clock
I am gonna just swiftly hand over to
Johnny let him take it from here because
the story starts with Johnny so thanks
so thank you thank you very much I'm
standing in a good place here lower the
screen yeah sure sure yeah so thank you
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you for for taking I know you're
all very busy so thank you for taking
the time out to come and come and listen
special thanks to Yale for this
opportunity and a special thanks to to
both Phil and to Cheryl as well
because they made this happen if it
wasn't for both of them we wouldn't be
here so really incredibly grateful
credibly grateful so we're gonna talk
about our personal story and actually we
always start by saying you know if
anything comes up for anyone at all
during the talk we talk quite frankly
and quite honestly about you know met
both mental health and suicide as well
and I know that can be very challenging
and if anything comes up for anyone at
all if it's too much please don't feel
you have to sit an injury if it's too
much please do takes and find out you
know exits it there yeah please do take
some time out don't don't cool you have
to sit and struggle then we're here to
talk afterwards we'd love to talk to you
afterwards as well so please do come and
talk to us I'm gonna take you back to
the very beginning of the story and
actually the story sorry before I do
that sorry before I do that I'm gonna
just show you a quick clip just I'll
show you the clip and I'll explain more
afterwards
looking for a man that changed my life I
just some so grateful to him for nothing
and talking it really was my recovery
started I said to maybe the one person
to come forward if they this was me but
actually had by a number of people on
board is it just a case of just wanted
to thank sort of your mug a trans map
where the hashtag find Mike is being
used which is coming in all the time
this guy could be this guy is
potentially I'm looking for surprise to
be honest one of the most uplifting
tales of our time the stranger on the
bridge Monday at 9:00 on four so that's
just a little preview of the film that
we both made and we'll tell you more
about that later on in the story but to
take you back to the very beginning of
where it all started
it started here so I was born on the
31st of January and 1987
in the in a in a place in North London
anyone from North London
yeah okay beam well that's same thing
yeah I was born in North London and I
grew up grew up with mum dad older
brother and I had a very kind of typical
childhood I suppose but for me things
started to change really around the age
of three four years old so when I was
this age I started to see things that
weren't there I started to hear things
that weren't there I became a lot more
anxious I became quite violent as well
my parents didn't understand you know
what was going on and they took me to
the doctors a few times then eventually
I was referred on to a child
psychologist this is the letter to the
psychologist I don't I don't really
remember much of our sessions to be
honest you know I was really young at
the time so I can't recall too much of
what happened but me and my parents we
we didn't know how to talk about it it
was very it was quite awkward it was it
was kind of embarrassing you know I was
seeing a psychologist at such a young
age so yeah it was a bit of a bit of a
tricky time meanwhile I started an
elementary school and I went through
elementary school I was always very you
know academic I was always very
hard-working but I always struggled
outside of the classroom I struggled to
fit in and to make friends and I just
felt very different to everyone else
growing up and that continued through
school and into my high school as well
this is me when I started high school
and I went to a really big Jewish High
School in North London and yeah the same
thing happened there I was very hard
working all the time but outside of the
classroom just found it very difficult
fitting in and making friends and it was
at this age that I started to hear a
voice in my head I thought that everyone
had a voice in their heads I just
assumed that you know if I was hearing a
voice and everyone must have a voice it
just made sense I was hearing what I
thought was the voice of an angel and I
think this a lot now I linked it a lot
to my my Jewish upbringing I was very
influenced by my faith growing up I went
to Sunday School I went to this Jewish
secondary school and I was really
absorbing a lot of what was being said
to me and you know I started to hear the
voice of this angel and I thought this
was great I thought this meant I was a
good Jew I also linked it now I lost my
grandmother around this time as well and
that was that was my first experience of
grief and I think there's a link between
that as well maybe but I thought
everyone had this voice so I thought
this was normal back then also around
this time I went to the cinema and I saw
and as everyone seen the film The Truman
Show which Jim Carrey so I saw the film
The Truman Show and then I had a best
friend at the time and I went to the
movies with my best friend and we came
out that the the theater and my best
friend he said to me he said you never
know but you could be in your own
version of The Truman Show he said he
said I could be an actor he said this
could all be a film set and I began to
really believe that yeah I was in this
film set I thought I knew where the
cameras were that we're watching me I
believe that everything was kind of set
up around me and if I'm honest I really
liked this back then I felt kind of
invisible at school it was such a big
school and I yeah I felt invisible but I
thought if I'm on this TV show then
people will like me and they'll see me
and they'll respect me you know so I was
quite happy with this at first things
changed in my mid-teens
this is me with my brother around the
age of sort of 1516 and and when I was
this age I started to get these really
low moods and I didn't I didn't
understand what was what was happening I
just I just felt incredibly low all the
time and I couldn't get out these these
moods and there was no reason for them I
just I didn't understand I was very
tearful the thing was we didn't talk
about mental health growing up when I
was in school the only thing that we got
was they showed us the film a One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest and that was it
that was kind of AA mental health
education and if you've seen that film
you know it's not exactly the most
inspiring film about mental health to be
honest and that film scared me it it put
me off talking I just I just didn't
understand what was happening like I
said to myself you don't come from a
really loving home and I was doing
really well in school so why was I
constantly feeling low it didn't didn't
make sense also around this time the
voice in my head changed so it went from
being this nice voice this angel to what
I thought was the devil and I linked
this a lot now to I was struggling with
my sexuality I'm coming from a Jewish
family and Jewish Jewish background you
know I was told being gay is a sin and
and I started to feel increasingly
guilty and ashamed and I think there's a
link between that and this change in
voice and this voice made life very
difficult
starts telling me to do things I would
always have to do things in threes I
would have to say certain things three
times or or touch things three times
pick pick things up and put them down
three times move three spaces
it was always things in threes that I'd
have to do by I felt like I had to do
them because the voice would say if you
don't do this I'm going to punish you
I'm going to punish someone that you
love so yeah made life made life made
life difficult I went when I was 17 I
went in secret to my doctor I didn't
want my parents to find out so I went in
secret to my doctor and my doctor was
really good I I told him some of what
was going on and he was he was good he
he referred me on to what's called AM
cams in the UK Cam's is the Child and
Adolescent Mental Health Service so the
mental health
this in the UK for young people and I
went for one appointment again in secret
by this time I really wasn't in a good
place in them yeah I said see right I
tried to hang myself in the school
toilet so suicide had come to the
forefront of my mind because it was too
difficult living with the low moods and
and the voice and having to do these
things and having to cover it up was
yeah it was very hard unfortunately
there was a long waiting list for
therapy after I had my assessment I
waited and I waited and I gave up
waiting and I I just said to myself you
know I've just got to just get on with
it just try and get on with it
I came up with a plan my plan was I was
gonna go to university I was gonna go to
university and I thought that would like
solve everything you know I was gonna
have a fresh start there's gonna be a
new me and I was going to leave
everything behind in in London and I
went to university I went to Manchester
which is north of England I went to
Manchester I went to university and
obviously everything came with me of
course to to university but I thought
everyone was having the time of their
lives
I thought everyone was happy you know
all the time at university and I thought
again I was the only one that was kind
of struggling with these things so again
I I kept it to myself but at university
things really began to spiral out of
control I began to self-harm and misuse
alcohol and just gradually isolate
myself away from everyone I mean now I I
felt I was crazy I told myself I was I
was crazy and insane and I didn't want
people to see or to know that so I tried
to isolate myself away from everyone but
everything did come out in my in my
final year of university so this is me
in November 2007 so yeah I was in my in
my third year in the first semester of
my third year my last year and at this
point I became psychotic so I lost
control over what I was saying and doing
like I ended up on the streets of
Manchester screaming and shouting and I
I felt like I was being possessed
I've kind of felt like the devil was
inside of me and yeah I just I was
things were coming out of my mouth oh it
wasn't me it wasn't my language it was
horrible experience I was taken to
hospital and then eventually I ended up
in a psychiatric hospital near my
parents in London and when I was when I
was admitted there I was given my
diagnosis which as you heard is
schizoaffective disorder and that for me
was a massive massive shock I knew
something wasn't wasn't quite right but
when the psychiatry said when
psychiatrist said schizophrenia sorry
for me that was kind of the end it felt
like my world just ended when I got my
diagnosis and for my parents as well
they thing came out for her for everyone
when I was admitted and I diagnosed by I
thought that was the end by the way the
story does get better just to say give
me give me three minutes and the story
will change but the reality was it was
very hopeless in the hospital where I
was no one around me was getting any
better
I started getting worse I start getting
these panic attacks for the first time
and a month into my stay I remember one
night something in me just snapped it
literally snapped in my head and I I
just I saw the only way out for me was
was suicide I there was no other way
really for me I back then I believed
that suicide was the best thing not just
for me but for my parents as well I was
I felt like I was gonna be a burden on
them for the rest of their lives so I
thought you know best just to end it
everyone it was the only way out and I
made a plan for the next day to leave
the hospital to run away and I did I
said I needed a cigarette and they let
me out of the hospital
then I ran as fast as I could and I
ended up on this bridge and I went on to
the edge of this bridge and I thought I
don't think I was on there for very long
and then this stranger approached me and
stood stood next to me and began talking
and I'm gonna hand over to obviously no
longer a stranger of course to to carry
on the story
hmm so I come into this story nearly 11
years ago now so there's no cute baby
pictures
just me in a tank top he's my opening
gambit maybe we all needed that at this
point anyway and okay so I'm 24 years
old I just decided I wanted to be a
personal trainer I also lived in a town
near North London called Watford don't
know if anybody's familiar with Watford
and so when I got this personal training
diploma I decided to move to London away
from my family home for the first time
and I moved to London and I was renting
a room with new flatmates I was dating
my new girlfriend Sarah at the time had
this new job ahead of me working at
virgin active health pubs which is out
Richard Branson's chain of health clubs
in the UK and yeah everything was pretty
rosy for me so I started that job in
November 2007 had a month at work and
went back to LA back to Watford from
London for Christmas and when I came
back to work in 2008 my first day back
to work was the 14th of January it was a
Monday morning and it was the same day
as you'd heard from Johnny that he'd run
away from the hospital
so I was making my way from my flat in
southwest London into central London and
I left my house really early that
morning and the first thing it was it
was absolutely freezing cold I was
making my way to Waterloo terminal train
station on the south side of Waterloo
Bridge and when I've got to Waterloo
terminal that morning yeah it was
freezing cold it was grey skies it was
raining and everybody coming out into
the rush hour was dressed for that
including me we all had big winter coats
gloves scarf hat and just marching over
the bridge trying to get to work
as possible but in the distance there
was somebody who stuck out like a sore
thumb
so unlike everybody else on the bridge
dressed up for winter you know well
firstly there was this guy who was
sitting on on the railings just on his
own and and the second thing was he was
just wearing a jeans and a t-shirt that
cold morning just shivering looking out
over the River Thames just in it his own
world and yet seeing that you know
obviously alarm bells start ringing and
any bridge in a big city it's very busy
there's so much going on the the buses
the cars to pedestrians cyclists tax
season and I think you really thought
you know before I get there somebody may
well talk to this guy and if they do
maybe I could lend a hand maybe I
wouldn't need to I could keep walking
and as I'm assessing this and it's going
on in my head I'm now the next person
that's walking past Johnny on the same
side of the bridge and I don't know
maybe in being a younger guy similar age
slightly better looking subjective I
thought you know maybe there's something
I could do to help you know so I just
started gravitating towards him and I
didn't know what I was going to say
that's all
so my chatot line wasn't great I said hi
mate why are you sitting on a bridge say
what you see so but that started our
conversation first conversation we had
and essentially he answered my question
he said I don't want to be here anymore
want to take my life he was actually
really shocked somebody was standing
next to him I completely pierced his his
bubble that he was in completely
pierce'sworld and but he answered my
question and I asked why and he started
to tell me about not not their voices
delusions but you know the pain needing
to find peace and you guys probably get
so yeah I had no idea no idea how to
navigate that conversation so simply
asking questions was the first instinct
just letting him open up but I had my
phone on me I wanted to try and get some
help and I asked Johnny if we could call
somebody that he knew maybe a family
member or but he was adamant that wasn't
an option his family didn't know he was
there and that's how he wanted it to be
and that he'd made his mind up and and
actually he didn't want me there you
know he was like look may I
see what you're trying to do thank you
just leave me alone and he was quite
rude but no he pushed on and you know
what happened over the next sort of 20
25 minutes or so was essentially we just
connected there was a natural chemistry
he allowed himself to open up and talk
but like I said after nearly half an
hour he was adamant that's my decision
today I was fresh out of ideas what to
do there's a coffee shop at the end of
the bridge on Waterloo Waterloo Bridge
and and I said to Johnny you want to go
for a coffee do you want to sit down and
and don't worry about tomorrow just look
at today I really needed it as well
coffee so he yeah something resonated
and that actually changed the whole
conversation he said okay he stepped
down from the side of the bridge and we
were side by side on the on the sidewalk
and we were about to go for that coffee
we didn't get the chance somebody had
called the police don't know who to this
day but the police turned up the way it
happened was a bit great but police car
came just screeching up beside us doors
opened and they knew why they were there
the police officers came out and just
made a beeline for Johnny and he
panicked he ran back for the side of the
bridge and when the police got involved
straightaway they thought the best thing
to do would be to handcuff Johnny head
down back to the police car close the
door and actually Johnny was there in
the back of the car by himself while I
gave my statement to the two police
officers but at the time nearly 11 years
ago I thought well you guys are the
professionals maybe you've been trained
for this situation and I guess that's
how you handle that situation so I
didn't think too much of it but yeah I
didn't seem quite right but anyway when
all that was over I gave my statement to
the police and they said thank you mate
please go back to work so so I did and
the police car drove away and I thought
you know best of luck mate I hope you're
okay and I'm not set up to experience
and get on with my day
and make sense of that later on which I
did I had absolutely no idea however the
by complete surprise six years later
that I was going to get to meet Johnny
again but under better sir
stances I'm gonna pass back over so just
to talk very briefly about about what
happened that day I think for me just
having someone there to to to really
listen in the hospital where I was you
know I I said a few times that I felt
suicidal and they would say to me right
well we need to up your meds now and and
you need to go back to the suicide ward
and the suicide ward is you know someone
that just sits and watches you 24/7 they
don't talk they just sit and they watch
and there was just never an opportunity
for you know someone to really listen
and and they listened with this amazing
kind of this this this patience and this
calmness and this empathy and
non-judgment and yeah it was very
powerful you know there were two key
things he said to me really
the first key thing he said to me was um
don't be embarrassed
you know that to feel embarrassed and
I'd never heard someone say that before
because I was that was the main that was
the main reason that I'd done this it
was not even put into words the
embarrassment and the shame around
everything in my heads my diagnosis my
sexuality as well just for someone to
say is fine though don't feel
embarrassed it's like a massive weight
off my shoulders and I began to talk I
felt I felt safe with this guy I thought
I could talk to him no judgment the
second key thing he said to me and to be
honest I think the thing that really
made all the difference he just said to
me very kind of casually he said you'll
be all right you'll get better and no
one has said that to me before in the
hospital where I was they were saying to
me and my parents you know we don't know
we you don't know what's gonna happen we
don't know but this guy had this kind of
conviction this conviction that I would
get better and just hearing that this
this this this conviction and this
positivity I wanted to I wanted to have
this coffee I wanted to carry on this
conversation and I stepped off the edge
onto the sidewalk and as you heard the
the
cops came along and I was taken away I
was sectioned that was given him section
two which means that you have to stay in
hospital for a certain period of time
once that was done I was then taken back
to the hospital that I ran away from and
I remember on the way back to the
hospital you know there was still the
kind of the same stuff going on in my
head but I felt different I had a little
bit of hope I think that's what it was I
had a little bit of hope from talking to
this guy and him saying you you you you
can't get better you you you know I had
this bit of hope that I hadn't had
before and this hope carried me through
the next few weeks and months and
eventually I was discharged when I was
discharged I was a different person
my psychiatrist said said to me and my
parents he said there he said you know
you're a shadow of the person that you
were before so if that was helpful but
it was true I didn't want to talk about
it I didn't have mental health issues
all my friends they were graduating from
University and and and and they were
moving forwards and I just I just fell
incredibly stuck and I did go back to
university actually I did go back and I
finished my degree there it was hard but
when I finished my degree I was just
completely lost I stopped taking all my
medication all in one go just yeah I
just had again something in me snapped
and I was just like I can't I don't want
to do this I want to be this person
anymore I stopped taking all my
medication and I became unwell again
this time I believe there was the
Messiah I I had all these visions I was
gonna I was gonna save the world
and I spent my time writing letter after
letter to all these important people
this one is to support knee didn't hear
back obviously after that I went through
a phase I I was like a reincarnation of
the singer Nina Simone and I believe
that was yeah reincarnation and I was
gonna be the next Nina Simone I can't
sing but I am I made all these record
demos and I sent them off to record
labels and you know I didn't hear back
from any of them either all of my early
twenties really we just spent
and stuck in my head I yeah I couldn't
talk about it no one could get through
to me it was it was tough but something
changed in my mid-twenties in my
mid-twenties a family friend of ours had
a heart attack a really major heart
attack and then I went to see him
afterwards and when we sat down and we
talked for ages he talked to me about
everything they had gone through from
the first pain in his arm while he was
driving you know to the he had a heart a
heart bypass and and and what that felt
like and what it felt like for him
living with this this heart condition
and I remember I sat there and I watched
him and I listened to him and I just
said to myself why can you talk so
openly and and so frankly about your
your health your physical health your
heart why can't I talk about my mental
health you know and I went home that
night and I wanted to talk like he'd
talked to me but I could never look
someone in the eyes and talk I know I
keep using this word but the
embarrassment I just I just couldn't I
just couldn't break through the
embarrassment so I went home that night
and I got my cameraphone out on my phone
I made a video it was easier talking to
the camera and I put this video on
YouTube actually I just wanted to just
connect to someone and I thought you
tubers would be a way to do that back
then I did it under a different name
like I've had a pseudonym I didn't want
my parents to see it but I might put it
out there and the response was amazing
it people started messaging me from from
all over the world and actually that's
our connection to these two amazing
people at the front which you'll hear
more about later
it was amazing getting all these
messages back from people people saying
to me you know I hear a voice so I've
had the Truman delusion you know this
Truman Show delusion
you know when I when I realized that I
wasn't alone in that it was such relief
and this helped me to talk I started to
make more videos it was helping me it
was helping other people and I think
this built my confidence to talk making
these videos and eventually I started to
talk to my family and you know I finally
was able to say you know
I've got mental health issues and I'm
gay and then that for me was the biggest
weight off of my shoulders it really was
the turning point because you know I
don't have to hide anything anymore
I could just be myself and yeah I felt I
suddenly found more human again and it
was at that point that I I said to
myself you know I wanna I want to try
and help people and I got involved with
this charity as you heard this charity
in the UK called rethink mental illness
who specifically focused on
schizophrenia and I sat down with them
one day and and I told them my story and
they said to me they said you know that
guy on the bridge that stopped you and
helped you have you ever thought of
trying to find him and to thank him and
you know I said you know I didn't know
where he was he could be anywhere how
would we find him and they said why
don't we launch a social media campaign
to find him
and we did we did six years to the day
that we first met on the bridge we
launched this social media campaign to
find the guy on national TV in the UK to
be honest if I'm completely honest I
didn't think that we'd find him but we
did it we did the campaign to raise
awareness of mental health but also
suicide as well suicide is a really
difficult difficult subject but we have
to talk about it you know it's in the UK
it's the biggest killer of men under 45
in the UK now it's the biggest killer of
both men and women under 35 and we need
to we need to talk about it so we wanted
to get people people talking and and we
launched this campaign I couldn't I
wasn't a hundred percent sure of his
name I thought his name was Mike his
name's Neil so I called the campaign
fine Mike this wasn't a good start
their response was amazing it went viral
it started trending it was very surreal
at one point the hashtag find Mike was
bigger than Beyonce bigger than Obama
very strange but the most extraordinary
thing happened
we actually had 38 people come forward
saying I think it was me that helped you
on the bridge literally one after the
other these people came forwards and it
was me was my dad it was my brother and
the most just extraordinary thing is
that all these people were genuine they
had stopped someone on a bridge in
London around that time all these we
call them these silent heroes you know
people like Neil that just on their way
somewhere and they're talking someone
off the edge of a bridge and just going
on their way and want to see they just
just astonishing stories but none of
them were the person that we were
looking for they all had different
accounts and and one week went into two
weeks and we thought we're not gonna
find them and then so I'm standing here
so a bit of a spoiler to the story but
ah you heard anyway but focus on the
journey as well as the destination so
I'm gonna be quite brief actually just
to make sure we can get everything out
in time so once the police car drove
away and and I had that short walk to
work in 2008 and when I got to work my
head was a muddle you know just try to
remember that conversation but it was my
first day back I'd only been there a
month I didn't know anybody particularly
well so I didn't want to tell them the
real reason I was late I thought if I
try to explain the experience that I
just had talking to Johnny that maybe
they would just dismiss it or change the
subject or maybe not even believe me so
I didn't mention it to anybody at work
that day or really going forward but
when I got home that night I called my
girlfriend Sarah she heard and you know
told her about the conversation over the
next few weeks a month when I saw close
friends and family for dinner you know I
tell them about this this conversation
and you know for me that felt good
enough just to kind of put it to bed in
my head and and yeah I felt fairly
positive actually about the interaction
however that was now my daily commute to
work for years to come I would come into
Waterloo terminal I'd go over Waterloo
Bridge into the central London and you
know I would always think you know
especially certain times of year you
know what happened to that guy you know
did he ever go back I wonder did he ever
take his life did his family find out
yeah so I mean that conversation always
always stuck with me and it was firmly
itched in my mind if you fast forward
then six years later and you know the
find Mike campaign it's all over
breakfast TV and radio and newspapers
and apparently I'm bigger than Beyonce
but I have no idea because I've missed
absolutely everything so so it's now
2014 I'm running my own business boot
camps retreats personal training
one-to-one and and yeah I'm working
early mornings late nights don't know if
anybody knows about that but not not
really watching the news and missed this
whole campaign the one person who
reconnected us actually another bizarre
twist of fate was Sarah who at this
point is now my fiancee she stuck with
me good girl and that's that's us a few
years ago and one night Sarah's on the
train home from work it's about ten
o'clock our week night to go to bed
Sarah's on the train home from London
and she calls me up and she's almost
frantic on the phone and she's like the
darling you need to sit down I've got
something I need to tell you I said I'm
lying down okay she said well it's about
a guy called Mike and I'm thinking don't
do this to me on the phone because you
know we're getting we're engaged I love
you and and she said no no no but when
she got it out she said you remember the
guy that you spoke to six years ago in
Waterloo Bridge and when I heard that it
took me a minute and I said yeah and she
said well I think he's looking for you
and I said what are you talking about
she called me after she'd read this post
on Facebook this is the exact post
actually that has been shared by rethink
and Johnny friend of a friend or a
friend and ended up on Sarah's Facebook
feed so I waited for her to get home
actually before I looked at it I was on
the phone with her she ran home from the
train station she got to the front door
and and I took her phone of her and I
looked at this post but
I didn't need to click the link and read
the story like she did because you know
his face was on there and and everything
came back to me as if it was yesterday
you know the whole conversation on the
bridge you know his voice everything I
did remember his name
so the same I'm over that's fine and
yeah that's that was when I saw it and I
saw everything unfold on TV but then
that night I found some of his YouTube
videos when I followed the links the
ones he made to help people and that's
when it really dawned on me and I watch
some of his videos with Sarah you know
wow he never went back he never took his
life he seems really happy he's helping
other people and and I think there's a
definite message there about random acts
of kindness and and I'm sure many people
in this room have done a random acts of
kindness or had one done unto them not
that mine that day was any bigger or
lesser than anybody else's but that
evening I actually got to find out how
my random act of kindness
turned out and and I think if we all
knew the consequence of those then we
probably all feel empowered to be more
aware so anyway I've got in touch with
rethink mental illness and came forward
I said my name's Mike but I'm Neil very
confusing for everybody
essentially a week after that email me
and Johnny were reunited and rethink
were filming the whole search as part of
this awareness campaign for suicide so
we're going to play you guys the clip of
when we met for the first well for the
second time but for the first time if
you know one of me when when he walked
through the door I was just the bag of
nerves I've never been so scared in my
whole life
I didn't instantly recognize him but
there was something there there was
something that was familiar about him as
he approached me I saw you in the TV
yeah I saw you speaking on the TV don't
be nervous honestly and then it was when
we sat down we Gant talking it was a
moment everything just came back to me I
could see him there on that bridge and
and there he was now he wanted me and it
was just he definitely said it's all
coming back now and I can remember your
mannerisms and I remember your voice and
you know I can see you you can tell like
he just he understands and he doesn't
judge and just sits there with it's kind
of this big smile and I think everyone
could do with the friend line now it's
hard to put two words actually what that
was like it was yeah sorry it was I was
very special very special to be able to
you know thank him and we talked when we
talked and we just forgot the cameras
were there it was yeah it's very very
special and after that one silver CIA
guys got his name way and Neal Neal said
to me know what can we do how can we
work together how can we help people and
we've been working together ever since
and it's it's been a remarkable
remarkable journey the best thing about
what we do is is getting messages such
as this which says thanks for the
various steps you've taken over the past
few weeks to highlight mental health
issues watching your story unfold stop
me from taking my own life so a big
thank you mate we need we need more more
stories of hope and recovery I don't
know what I don't know what it's like in
the US but in the UK for a long time
speed so many negative stories you know
when it comes to mental health and we
need to change that after that our
documentary the stranger on the bridge
came out on on channel 4 and that was
really well
sieved in the UK and and and there's
lots of doors opening up for us and
we've got another just quick video just
to show you some of the highlights of
the last few years of working together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm no label I'm Johnny Benjamin we've
got a really busy day ahead of us just
arrived in Belfast
we're now at Schroeder's today we fly
out to some films in Canada finishing up
I overcame adversity and if I can
overcome any adversity then then you can
as well you really need to support each
other and don't be afraid to ask if if
you need support as well
so we're in the last mile very honored
to give you this and I'm very grateful
because I'm a person who could very
easily been sat on that bridge that was
Neils how I was that kiss from Russell
Brand's it's no it's it's yeah it's been
an amazing amazing journey I think for
me my highlight was running the London
Marathon lost last year we ran the
London Marathon together and at one
point towards the end of the marathon we
actually ran underneath the bridge where
we first met
and that was really kind of wow you know
we had that conversation up there and
now we're running the marathon together
was again it was very very special for
me it was even more special
I just come out of hospital at the time
I had a relapse last February and went
back into hospital when I've had a few
we got relapses over the last few years
and you know and I know I have to manage
my my mental health and I do that in
different ways I take medication now and
a no medication maybe isn't for everyone
but for me I think it keeps me
relatively stable and balanced I I have
therapy now and at the moment I'm having
something called s EFT which is
compassion focus therapy and that's been
really yeah really interesting really
interesting and helpful for me and the
other thing that's really helped me
massively is mindfulness massively
helped me I mean it doesn't switch
everything off but it stops things from
being so intense and overwhelming
through things like meditation or yoga
it's it's been a massive help I think
more than anything is talking it's
talking and it's being honest and open
and and having support
I'm very lucky to have the support I
have yeah but the thing that keeps me
going I think the most is the work that
we do and my particular passion is young
people we know that three-quarters of
all mental health issues begin in
adolescents so it doesn't make sense why
we don't do more in schools so two years
ago we launched this workshop as you
heard which is called think well and
think well is run by pixel learning and
it goes around schools all over the UK
but it's not enough
trying to get mental health embedded
into the curriculum you know why don't
we talk about mental health within
different subjects so in history for
example there's so many people in
history that have mental health
challenges like Winston Churchill or
Abraham Lincoln or Florence Florence
Nightingale why can't we talk about that
with it in school or in science you know
why do we never learn about the brain or
in in English you know we I remember we
studied a Romeo and Juliet and at the
end of Romeo and Juliet they both killed
themselves unfortunately but I remember
my teacher just pretended it didn't
happen and you know she said write your
essay and we were just sitting there we
were just all gobsmacked you know
they've just taken their lives and we're
not going to talk about that so we want
to get mental embedded into the
curriculum and we think it can make a
massive difference and we're doing work
both in the UK but also also abroad this
was a trip to India
a couple of years ago to work with all
these young people and hundreds of these
these these young people living in an
orphanage near Mumbai and unfortunately
they all have HIV but because they've
got HIV you know their physical health
is being who's being treated it was
being monitored it's being addressed a
lot of these young people have had a lot
of trauma and but no one wanted to talk
about their trauma or or look at their
mental health so we were working with
the young people and with the adults as
well on looking at preventative tools
you know we we just don't focus enough
on on prevention you know we focus on
mental health of the crisis end you know
when things go wrong but if we can take
it all the way back to the prevention
stage it can make such a massive
difference so that's one of the huge
areas that we're working on I just like
to segue into the colleagues that we're
here with today so since meeting Jonny
in 2014 for the second time that's when
I guess my perception of mental health
or my thinking about mental health had a
paradigm shift in beginning to work with
rethink becoming an ambassador and the
role of an alloy somebody who's there to
listen but also to hear from people who
had lived experience of mental health so
I started this journey understanding
learning more and we did a lot of
awareness in
in hospitals and schools and and in the
NHS and National Health Service in the
UK mmm after the documentary came out
that's when organizations private sector
really started getting in touch with us
and saying you know can you can you come
in and start to do some work because
there's a big crisis in in the workforce
and and so we again just more experience
and more learning and that essentially
got me thinking about well that's just
the UK but what about other places
around the world you know these these
organisations for example I'm sure Yale
I don't know the intricacies but I'm
sure you guys have a big international
reach and and how can we help those
organizations just to make a linked up
approach with their networks and and get
this message out there we couldn't do it
alone so we we'd flown out to Texas in
2014 to go on a Glenn Beck show you know
glim Beck was apparent ease a big deal
here we said yeah trip to Texas great
that's where we met Johnny Quinn and I'm
gonna let Johnny just tell you guys a
little bit about our sort of us work
before I do that just to leave you guys
in a very the message of hope and
recovery and the power of conversation
when it comes to to mental health and so
I'm gonna I'm gonna pass over to Johnny
and hopefully we're gonna have five
minutes for questions before one o'clock
so so thank you good afternoon everyone
so yeah really briefly actually I'll
start our little bit of the story by
saying in 2011 my family went through a
really interesting journey I came out to
my parents and then a month later I'm
gonna give him like ten seconds to stand
up and just this is Wesley hi my name is
Wesley and like Johnny Quinn said in
2012 in 2011 I was diagnosed with
schizophrenia and from there we kind of
long story short we met Johnny and Neil
on when we connected you know things
just kind of fell in place and this way
here today and we've been working
together ever since and so that was a
month after I came out so I was like
really happy about this you know new
thing about myself
then the other foot dropped and it was
like oh no how do we deal with this we
didn't know anything about it it was
very surreal for us and I as Johnny
mentioned came across Johnny Benjamin's
YouTube page and it was really inspiring
for me because I was in a place and my
family was in a place where we didn't
know if we were gonna get my brother
back we thought okay we might physically
still have him but where is he you know
do we get him back and I saw this young
man he was so charismatic so creative in
front of the camera and it showed me
that people can have one of the most
mysterious diagnoses and still go on to
be you know very active in life and very
present
so as Neil mentioned we all met well
first of all I introduced Johnny to
Wesley I went on YouTube made a comment
on the video didn't expect to hear back
but I asked would you please help my
brother through his recovery do you have
tips etc he not only helped they sort of
became pen pals
I got a chance to meet Johnny in London
and we sort of started this back and
forth communication and then in 2014 we
get a call from a producer in Texas and
they wanted to fly us out and surprise
Johnny Benjamin who was being
interviewed on Glenn Beck's TV show the
blaze is what it was called I think so
we all four met there and you know it
was really fun we actually went out one
night and got really drunk I think I
remember slapping Neil in the face which
she usually doesn't happen the first
time I meet someone and he slapped me
back that's just how good of a night it
was and and so we really bonded and uh
and fast forward seventeen so alone okay
we had always talked about maybe doing
something together I had a tech startup
throughout most of my 20s and there was
a lot of creative energy so they asked
if I could help them bring their
awareness work to the u.s. and I was
like that's a great opportunity I would
love to do that and as well because of
things that I saw that weren't there for
my brother when he was going through his
recovery friends that ran away
dreams career dreams that were put on
hold I was like I'd really like us to
also start thinking
about you know ways we can use your guys
story our reach to get creative in terms
of social development not just in terms
of medical recovery but helping people
feel entitled just like everyone else
does to participate in life whether it's
career whether it's dating whether it's
friendship what-have-you so we created
an initiative called you alright mate
the name comes from the British
expression you're right you know like it
says this the one thing I remember after
I go to London but uh but you know the
idea there was that you know not to just
think of that as a rhetorical question
but also like genuinely being able to
turn to people see how they're doing and
this initiative is not just about
helping the people who are suffering but
also the people around them
develop the tools the patience the
language to to you know be there for
them so this is a combination of
awareness like we're doing today but
also we're starting to venture into
organizational support we've done a lot
of you know we've had a big presence in
the corporate sphere building off of
relationships they've had we're also
excited about you know relationships
with universities and we really want to
be bold and say that we're going to
develop things that maybe do not exist
yet that help people beyond the initial
recovery to actually you know feel
entitled to play whatever role in life
that they want to regardless of what's
going on in their head so that's you
alright mate in a nutshell and I'm going
I'm not sure whom the mic goes to next
but thanks so yeah I think I think
actually we would just welcome any any
questions while we have time and we just
again just like to say thank you to yo
University thank you to Philip and
Cheryl who have been amazing host and
very hospitable and and please just
remember the the message of hope and
recovery and beyond when you're thinking
about mental health not only with
yourself but those people around you and
then who you might be able to affect so
so thank you and please somebody ask at
least one question it would make us feel
at home thank you so when here we are a
little tight for time but let's have
some questions yeah John you've you just
took yourself off meds how did you
recover do you know what actually I
think yeah I mean I'm on medication now
but yeah I took myself off meds and it
was a mess for quite a while and then
actually um so when I was in hospital at
the first time a nurse she pulled me
aside and she said to me she said have
you ever have you ever tried any
mindfulness and I said I said no and she
said she said get this get this thing
it's called our mindfulness for
beginners by someone called Jon
kabat-zinn people and it was an audio
book and I got I got the audio book and
to be honest it sat on my shelf for a
few years because I I was just like I
can't I can't meditate I can't do
mindfulness I can't
but then after yeah while after I
stopped taking my meds I was like I need
I need to I need to do something and I
just I put this CD on it's mindfulness
for beginners and it really there was
something something in it that just
changed everything for me and I did so
there's two to see these with this
mindfulness for beginners that the first
CD is Jon kabat-zinn talking about
mindfulness and its benefits and the
second CD is actually it's that it's a
range of different meditations and I
remember doing my first mindfulness
meditation it's just a 10 minute
meditation and I'll never forget I went
to I just went to wash my hands
afterwards and I put the tap on and I
was washing my hands and there was peace
of mind there was silence and you know
all I heard was the water running and
the birds were singing outside and I was
just like I had peace of mind I have
some peace of mind and that was just
extraordinary that was an extraordinary
experience and I was like I can I can
somehow find some peace of mind so that
was something that for me I know
mindfulness maybe doesn't it's not for
everyone but for me I think that made a
huge huge difference yeah
thank you so much for sharing your story
with us and having that courage
my question is to journey you again and
I was wondering how did you overcome the
urge of self punishment and feeling that
you were burdening those around you yeah
I still it's an ongoing thing to be
honest it's ongoing
yeah it's ongoing I think for me
learning about self compassion
I mean when I read this book this the
Kristin Neff that her book on self
compassion kind of scared me I was like
oh my goodness I'm so so hard on myself
I'm so embrittle I was brutal with
myself it was you know awful and
learning about self compassion and and
and starting this compassion focused
therapy it's mccredle be lucky to have a
Arabist
in London he's called he's called
Charlie Harriet Maitland and then I
don't know he might be worth having a
look online he's got some amazing videos
on on compassion for people that hear
voices amazing amazing guy
and anyway starting the the CFT the
compassion focus therapy that's really
helped - yeah - stop beating myself up I
mean I say it's a lot I've done two
years now of therapy and it's ongoing
and it's a lot of work but that's been a
massive hole that's been a massive help
that the compassion the compassion we
don't talk enough about compassionate
self compassion I think my therapist is
called Emma Charlie Charlie Harriet's h
er I Oh T Maitland ma itla MD he he
works very closely with her Elinor
Longdon and I'm sure some of you might
be familiar with Ellen in London and her
amazing TED talk about you know the
voice the voices in her head she did the
TED talk
he works together with her so I'm afraid
there's another group who are trying to
come in so she want to say thank you
again this was absolutely fabulous
[Applause]
[Music]